as Israel response to the terror attacks
that have killed over a thousand people
some Democrats are apparently not
comfortable calling out the evil
disturbing reports are mounting of the
brutality that Hamas has inflicted on
the people of Israel including
Unthinkable acts of violence toward
women and children President Biden has
been calling out the sheer Act of evil
but Squad representative Rashida TB
turning her back when asked Point Blank
about
it terrorists have um cut off babies
heads and burn children alive do you
support Israel's rights to defend
themselves against his brutality we're
just going to go through here you have
no comment about children's heads being
chopped
off Congressman why do you have the
Palestinian flag outside your office if
you do not condone what Kamas terrorist
have done to
Israel nearly 24 hours after that
congresswoman TB is responding saying in
an interview I do not support Target and
killing of civilians whether in Israel
or Palestine the fact that some have
suggested otherwise is offensive and
rooted in bigoted assumptions about my
faith and ethnicity the White House
condemning Squad democrats for their
disgraceful
comments we believe they're wrong uh we
believe they're repugnant and we believe
they're disgraceful uh our our
condemnation belongs squarely with
terrorists who have brutally murdered
raped kidnapped hundreds hundreds of
Israelis
uh there can be no equivocation about
that there are not two sides here there
are not two sides SL is not the only one
causing outrage a Chicago chapter of
black lives matters posting this now
deleted tweet it shows the image similar
to the paragliders Hamas terrorists used
when they massacred over 200 people at a
concert the chapter deleted the post and
now say they aren't proud of the
messages they sent out but they continue
to quote stand with Palestine and the
people who will do what they must to
live free I want to play this for you as
well President Biden just gave some
remarks in which he made a very strong
statement about
silence silence is
complicity I'm not I mean silence is
complicity it really is and I want you
to know I think you've already figured
it out I refuse to be silent I know you
refuse to be silent as
World Brett Hillary vaugh trying to get
Rashida to answer those questions she's
Intrepid right she was and and then T
refuses to answer of course she gives an
interview later on but why would it be
that hard I mean where's the courage and
bravery if you're going to put the
Palestinian flag outside her office okay
great then explain but instead she just
turned her back and walked away yeah I
don't think there's an answer I mean if
you look at all of the things that we're
seeing every day uh coming in from those
families coming in from the children
it's not Soldier on Soldier this is
Terrorist on baby Terrorist on family so
it's not defensible and I think that
that's why there was no response for 24
hours I will say that the Administration
has done a pretty good job of kind of
responding to this right away and
forcefully not you know usually they've
kind of been around the edges this was
pretty forceful and they did a pretty
good job of it and I think that judge it
was clear to me that when Karen
jeanpierre the press secretary says what
she says against the squad like that was
coming directly from the boss yeah I
don't think there's any question and I I
joined Brett uh in in it recognizing
that that the president and his staff so
far has made it clear that this is wrong
and you know when the president um
talked just now about silence as
complicity it was Ellie wiisel who says
silence encourages the Tormentor never
the tormented to do nothing helps the
abuser never the victim and what we've
seen in this country for too long tells
you all you need to know about Rashida
Talib and her gang that she couldn't
recognize this as evil that she wasn't
able to say it's wrong tells you
everything you need to know and for
years in this country we've been mired
in this area of like a gray fog what are
we saying that hurts your sensitivities
hurts your feeling how should I feel
according to the way you feel what
microaggressions am I causing you to
suffer but now when we're confronted
with real evil it's time for us to put
on our big boy pants and say this is
what we have to stop this is what we
have to confront and it's time to start
recognizing ing that when they're done
over there they're coming over here and
if anyone thinks especially Rashida
Talib that these children that were
burned alive or that were beheaded were
beheaded after their mothers were
murdered they're wrong the last
infliction of harm on these mothers was
to make them watch their babies die so
the people who can't tell the difference
are sheer sociopaths and they have the
audacity the next day to call it truce
after this kind of violence no there
should be no Tru no truce we should arm
Israel to the teeth we've got to destroy
Hamas control the violence in Gaza to
prevent an allout war and do it fast
Jessica your thoughts today um I would
Echo the sentiments from brat and the
judge about this um I think that
President Biden has been appropriately
forceful I'm glad to see how much it's
being appreciated over in Israel as well
I've seen a lot of reports coming out
that he has served as a a sort of bomb
something that can actually soothe you
at a moment when you're living in
complete abject Terror um adding on to
the eloel point obviously that's
Holocaust from related and I'd like to
call that out explicitly that Joe Biden
using those terms means that what
they're seeing now is AK kin to what
happened when six million Jews um were
exterminated and that's very forceful as
far as Rashida Talib um someone that I
have spoken out against a number of
times she has made it perfectly clear
that she doesn't think two-state
Solutions work and and we know which
side she's picking right if a two-state
solution isn't feasible but she also
missed an opportunity so she has a
Palestinian flag outside of her office
because she's Palestinian she's the only
Palestinian member of Congress and I
think she has every right to have that
but when you're being asked about it why
do you not take the opportunity to say
Palestine and Hamas are different this
has nothing to do with Palestinians my
heart breaks for Israelis and it breaks
for innocent gazin you know gaza's half
children you know and and I don't know
why she was very upset stenny Hoyer
actually came to her defense yesterday
saying um she's beside herself about
what's going on like give her a second
on this but if you had the time to then
process it and come back for that
interview educate people about the
Palestinian people and that they have
respect for human life and that Hamas
has corrupted that message if that is
what you feel about it and the people in
pales in the Palestinian Authority are
victims of Hamas correct as well Greg I
want you to listen to everybody Listen
to Not Just Greg this is a crowd in
Michigan call for number one uh and
their views about
[Music]
Hamas no
justice your flags up no
justice free free Palestine free free
pal free free
Palestine free free palese so you listen
to that but also looking at the video
Greg that's not a small gathering no
it's not it's kind of scary uh I mean
when you think about we talked about BLM
we talked about the squad and then you
see these crowds in Dearborn are these
people evil or are they stupid I think
that the leaders are weak and scared
because they've ridden to prestige on a
terrible message that has played into
what you just saw that population right
and they can't piss them off with with
stupid ideas like empathy or compassion
because that just means you're weak and
you're going back on your pernicious
ideology when you can't say that
beheading kids is evil you pretty much
removed yourself from Humanity pretty
safe to say but it's all due to this
sunk cost of years of believing in a
terrible ideology that lineage makes you
evil that lineage prevents groups of
people from actually working towards
peace it's ironic that progressives
don't believe in progress they believe
in the past you see this language here
I'm not talking about just Israel I'm
talking about here because that's here
it's now we saw language early on White
Privilege that's a racist term that
deemed you an oppressor based on lineage
the neo-marxist push uh by the
progressive left that shaped BLM that we
must punish the colonizers who are the
colonizers those are the people with
white privilege hence the free punch
which again riots looting murder
defunding the police and if you dare
question it if you dare question it in
those years after after the uh um the uh
George Floyd uh death God help you
because the media defended this
destructive impulse all the way through
practically fundraising for BLM you know
the whole point is America we tried to
create a place where lineage didn't
matter of course it's a work in progress
right but it was progress that we called
it a Melting Pot for a reason and now we
have people cheering barbarity and it's
not just about the Jews it's about us
when they shout when they shout
colonizer they're talking about you too
there's so much ideological overlap here
with BLM and Hamas and radical gender
militants and activists it's lineage
that your past is your crime as an
oppressor for simply existing the origin
story of you is a stain that must be
scrubbed from the earth that's why this
is scary that's why you should be
worried when you see those crowds out
there it's not enough to just say hey
this is this one moment is bad you know
our future misery is
Downstream hi everyone I'm Brian killme
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now